hi everyone I'm Catherine Langford I'm
Jayden Martel Chris Evans I play ransom
Drysdale Daniel Craig I played Ben
welcome hi I'm Jamie Lee Curtis and I'm
Don Johnson and I'm gonna participate
with Jamie Lee Curtis uh-huh hi guys I'm
a además i'm ryan johnson and i wrote
and directed an episode which anistar is
it and we are gonna take a quiz to find
out if we would survive a murder mystery
party won't that be so fun I feel like
I'm 14 first things first what dish are
you serving at your party lasagna
Cornish game hens beef wellington no
food just drinks ratatouille your
lobster bisque I'm serving beef
wellington I'm gonna go to the thought
yeah listen yeah and there's your little
Italian finger and then you get it I'm
gonna go with lasagna white lasagna good
that's easy to make even though I'm
lactose intolerant so that's not a good
choice for me let's go write it to it
why ratatouille easy ratatouille I just
remember watching that film when I was
little and you know it was a good movie
sing I'm gonna serve some lasagna beef
wellington I'm gonna go for yeah they
like the lasagna or just no food just
drinks I'll do the drinks you do the
lasagna let's see we're gonna split up
and see we're not supposed to yeah yeah
I think I'll go in furnace onion yeah
okay yeah I'm just I'm just drinkin pick
a weapon from the game Clue a knife a
candlestick a vial of poison a revolver
a rope a lead pipe I mean you gotta go
with the revolver I'm not an idiot
I like the lead pipe you would well when
I was a kid playing with a vial of
poison because I'm a nurse you're a
nurse that accessory you go the revolver
cuz that way it came with that cool
multi-barreled revolver as a token yeah
that's the one you always want to get as
a kid I'm gonna candlestick because man
if you can do something like that I'm
gonna go with a lead pipe my leg pot
seems impractical but it definitely can
kill someone with that but I think a
knife a knight given the history of my
room and yeah bounty yes sure play a big
part in their life that's something yes
I know pick an iconic detective Sherlock
Holmes Velma from scooby-doo Harriet
from Harriet the Spy Nancy Drew Hercule
Poirot from Murder on the Orient Express
monk from monk I love Sherlock Holmes
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do [ __ ] crimes
he is brainy a bit weird this is the
wrong there to do guys I'm thinking
about Nancy Drew hidden staircase
featuring Sophia Lilith I don't have to
go with that one
to honor my friend octave a gem on your
mind I'm gonna do part row Graham Bell
look oh I was gonna go above another
both always although we'll do it we can
begin begin each we can pep up gentlemen
that's okay so what are the rules I'm
going Velma I'll go with Adrian the monk
pick a motive love power money property
family it was an accident
let's go with love that's the most
interesting one love is pertinent
try and think how can you kill someone
with a candlestick and her love bad
dinner I'm breaking up with you
Oh woods love I was gonna say love to we
can't have the same images let's do that
present a you daughter you took it okay
yeah well press let's go ahead and then
did you this great I'll see family money
yeah yeah I mean duh yeah it's all money
it's all about money right yeah alright
I'm gonna do money - it's always about
money it's never an accident
she's a suspicious blonds okay so we
have lieutenant Elliot and Caitlin Keith
Stanfield Marta Cabrera Linda Drysdale
won't thrombi I can't make from the or
ransom Drysdale I can't pick myself can
i I'll take lieutenant Elliot what I got
you great yeah
class go on Jail see Linda Dee yeah okay
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna have to go with
Marta
she looks suspicious you guys all look
very suspicious the only one who can
make lasagna is Linda dry it's true look
at look at her she's sterile I like the
way you're looking I'm clicking on you
I'll do it Martha Cabrera you're looking
at that bird very suspiciously
you think that Birds about to let loose
on your head alright I'm going with
Linda okay
ransom trying it out that's pretty
creepy look I'm gonna Keith the keith
has got a good stare
how would your friends just I discovered
it personal how would your friends
describe you honest ambitious kind loyal
hard-working intuitive
how would your friends describe you or
how would your friends you would hope
they would describe you I don't like ho
I like your version
I'm taking over for millennia and I'm
turning it into with her something's
about to die so I'm gonna say I hope
they were members of being kind honest
he went honest dough in kind the word
I'm thinking of isn't there okay not
other words honest ambitious they're all
nice performing on of it my friends say
no thanks to me I'll say loyal tiny yeah
I'm getting kind
I'll like ambitious you're gonna be able
to survive if I feel like yeah and if
you're honest then maybe you're not a
good liar yeah as a humble hopefully
okay I'm going
honest okay video on us as well I'm
going to say kind I would say that yeah
you soon yeah I was gonna go for a heart
work you're working your lately you've
been she's done like four movies in a
row I think you're hard-working
qualifies yeah
finally for fun pick a donut oh yes this
is the treat strawberry sprinkle truck
with sprinkled glazed berry drizzle
jelly doughnut holes took it down i
laced glaze huh you like the most boring
donut on them yeah pleased i'm glazed
alright
you and me both you know if i have a
jelly doughnut near me I'd go for the
jelly what are you doing blaze you go
for the glaze woman
so you're very drizzle I picked
strawberry sprinkle it don't copy me Oh
a pajama covering you
oh I did not make it I survived my I
survived as well so ha ha ha
we both survived right you made it
through to the very end duh
congratulations on being alive hopefully
this doesn't ruin parties for you in the
future
unfortunately you met your demise at the
this fair but if it makes you feel
better you thought you were just going
to a party you didn't know there was
going to be a murder on the menu you're
the mastermind behind this entire
operation you almost got away with it
too but as you know the truth always
comes out in the end
hey I'm sure you had your reasons money
wah ha ha ha sorry I killed you
[Music]